foreign
let's go
good morning everyone the sitting is
open
one announcement the political groups
and non-attached members have notified
me of appointments to the new
subcommittee on public health the list
of the subcommittee members will be
published online and in
the minutes next item on the agenda is
European Council and commission
statements conclusions of the special
European council meeting of the ninth of
February and preparation of the European
council meeting of the 23rd and 24th of
March 2023 I start by giving the plot to
the president of the European Council
Michelle
thank you
my name is
madam president of European Parliament
president of the commission ladies and
gentlemen the last European Council was
marked by the participation of President
Vladimir zielinsky he took part in a
brief plenary session where we had the
occasion to reaffirm our full support
for Ukraine for as long as it takes
because defeat for Ukraine is not an
option
then met in small formats with leaders
about intensifying the direct
operational assistance especially for
more weapons
to win the peace we must strengthen our
defense and our capabilities in three
days after the Russian attack we took
the decision to deliver arms and
Munitions to Ukraine and this marked a
paradigm shift I believe this was the
birth of our European Defense
strengthening our European Defense means
developing our industrial capacities and
disease
urgently needed to support Ukraine
Russian forces have fired between 20
000 and 50 000 artillery shells per day
in recent months Ukraine needs
ammunition to defend itself and that's
why we have worked on the proposal of
Estonian prime minister kayakalas to
organize build orders to support the
pace of our deliveries to our Ukrainian
friends and high representative borrel
has developed a concrete plan to
implement this assistance to Ukraine
ladies and gentlemen
we would like to see an escalation we
would like to see an escalation towards
peace but Russia has not start a state
in the war
it would only take one decision just one
decision from the addresser to engage in
peace to sell the weapons and to
withdraw its troops behind the
internationally recognized borders of
Ukraine unfortunately we do not see any
signal from the Kremlin in this
direction and this by this we continue
to fight a battle for peace The
Diplomatic battle we support the just
peace formula proposed by President
zelinski it is based on the U.N Charter
it is based on the respect for the
international law and we are working
hard to Rally the International
Community behind peace efforts like we
did in the run-up to the vote in the U.N
General Assembly call in for the
withdrawal of Russian forces from
Ukraine territory we also discussed for
instance this with many contacts at the
recent African Union Summit United
Bieber and the high representative went
to the United Nations in New York for
the vote the resolution was supported by
an overwhelming majority of 141
countries this vote is encouraging but
the work of convincing others remains
extremely challenging
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
The Economic Consequences of the war in
Ukraine
have forced us to ask ourselves the
right questions about the
competitiveness of our economy both in
the short and long term
just one example to illustrate the
challenge
the eu's energy trade deficits in 2022
we presented some four percent of our
GDP compared with 1.7 percent in 2021
while the United States has seen its
Surplus increase three faults during the
same periods energy export in the United
States have increased by 60 percent in
last December the European Council asked
the permission to present ways of
helping our Industry Drive forward our
green and digital transition especially
in the context of more targeted State
interventions including by the United
States and we have decided on our
short-term strength of action
first relaxing the stated regime in a
targeted and time limited way cattled
with greater flexibility in the use of
all existing financial means certain
point making life easier for our
businesses by streamlining procedures
and authorization
and third step in depth training and
retraining to provide our future sectors
with the professionals the desperately
need
but ladies and gentlemen we also must
take action in the long term because we
cannot allow the short-term measure to
undermine our long-term strategy and
this is exactly precisely the debate we
will have next week at our next European
Council on the competitiveness of the
European economy and we expect the
proposals requested from the commission
tomorrow
in the long term I think we need to work
on three areas investment Innovation and
trade first investment European
companies particularly smes are having
difficulty find the capital they need to
invest in Innovation the gap between the
EU and the United States in terms of
productive investment represents two
percent of GDP another example the EU
stock market capitalization is less than
half debt of the us as a proportion of
gross domestic product and yet Europeans
save far more than Americans we must
close this job and we know the solution
there is a solution this is called the
Capital Market Union a project whose
foundations were laid almost 10 years
ago and it's not crucial that we speed a
positive work to bring this essential
project to fruition to finance our
autonomy to create jobs and to ensure
the well-being of all Europeans for
decades to come
and that's also why together with the
commission the president of the European
Central Bank and the European Investment
Bank and the present Euro group we have
publicly launched this accelerated call
to work together with the
um Market ladies and gentlemen the
second Point uh we're working on is
innovation we're all aware that
the Lisbon strategy set the ambitious
goal of three percent of GDP which
should be dedicated to mobilizing uh
capacities for innovation
we can see that the results have not
been up to the objectives that we set we
have to do more we have to do better
and this will also be on the agenda of
the council uh this week for example if
you look at digital platforms
90 percent
of capitalization for the 70 biggest
companies in the world come from the
United States and China so that shows
how little capacity the European Union
has that it can deploy in such important
sectors
the third sector
is trade
I want to share some Reflections on
trade with you
for many years
I would say that trade was a sacred
instrument for the European Union it's
been able to derive Prosperity capacity
development and to improve living
conditions for our citizens
today we have to be very clear
we are in the Champions League when it
comes to negotiating trade agreements
but we have a lot more difficulty when
it comes to implementing this agreement
since 2006 the uh of the trade
agreements have been negotiated must
have been implemented only in a
provisional fashion not entirely or have
not been implemented for example in the
coming months we'll be working with
mercosur and Chile
and working with Mexico to look at a
number of issues that have to be tackled
face on
so when it comes to trade policy in the
future there are a couple of points we
have to look at one are methods for
negotiating we have to be able to ensure
that we involve everyone who was
directly affected that everyone should
feel involved in the process to ensure
that we have more transparency and more
trust an example of this is brexit
we have had to make available all
information that we had without any uh
with full transparency to make sure that
it's available for the parliament for
Citizens and to allow us to work quickly
and we should use this as our
inspiration for methodology going
forward then we have to look at the
substance
there seems to be a desire to want to
solve a lot of problems through trade
policy and negotiations but perhaps we
have to make a choice a trade agreement
can help to improve uh things
and this should be an objective in under
trade negotiations and that it should
also be used to encourage more support
around the world for the demanding
standards that we want to see for
example when it comes to working
conditions or environment conditions
we should have this uh democratic debate
and it's very clear that the European
Parliament has a key role to play here
finally we have to look at our future
our competitiveness and to do that we
have to look at the relationships that
we have with other key players around
the world the United States of course
but also China
and here
in line with the treaties the council
fully intends to shoulder its
responsibilities when it comes to
European Union external policy
we've had strategic debates on a number
of occasions in the European Council
over recent months
and a couple of Reflections on this
first of all
we know that
China and the United States aren't
equidistant from us we are a loyal
faithful partner of the United States
and we want to focus on our historic
links focused on values as well as
economic policy which
as we know is also important to our
security however at the same time China
is a
key actor on the international stage and
that's a fact and so there are a number
of points that we have to focus on in
our relations with China first of all we
have to stand firm look one another in
the eyes defend our values democracy
human rights that are so important to us
we also have to engage to try to reduce
dependency which can be so expensive we
can see this we saw this with Russia and
energy so to rebalance economic
relations with China
particularly when it comes to strategic
points for the future prosperity of
Europe and then thirdly I don't think
anyone here is in any doubt that we have
to engage with China on global issues
for instance issues relating to climate
change
or health
and so it's in this perspective that we
will continue to work to engage in the
council with European external policy
and working with the countries that we
uh have relations with and finally just
to conclude
on a topic of no less importance
the European Council is an opportunity
to look in detail at the issue of
migration we know that migration
is an issue which is leading to
political and ideological tensions it's
often used to drive
polarization within our societies I
think we need to be rational in
analyzing this issue we know that the
European Parliament is doing work with
the rotating presidencies in order to
ensure that the migration pact is
abruptly implemented this is the
internal aspect of migration and we
encounter will also ensure that we can
act and make progress on this topic in
coming months
in the meantime however it's true that
we can also do more and do better when
it comes to cooperating with third
countries countries of origin countries
of Transit
cooperate more to fight uh criminals and
traffickers
who are speculating on poverty and human
misery
to do more to open up legal migration
channels
not
leave it to the criminals and the
traffickers to decide who can come to
Europe for us to take decisions
respecting the rule of law to ensure
that there are Humane regular channels
and so next week we'll also be having an
update on the discussions on this topic
since the last European Council
and to finish we'll also have an
opportunity to look at the situation in
the Eurozone
we'll have
um Christine lagarda will be looking at
the future of the Eurozone so finally
ladies and gentlemen colleagues
we are all aware that for a number of
years now
we have been facing difficult times
we have questioned uh many issues but
the fundamentals remain
we have to focus on our values these
should be our guiding compass in the
future
to ensure that we have a sovereignty
strategic autonomy that we need more
resilience and have to be more
influential in the world reduce
dependency and hopefully this will be a
guiding principle for all of us working
on this project that is so important to
each and every one of us here thank you
very much
[Applause]
honorable members
last Friday I met with President Biden
in Washington
we had a very good discussion on the
inflation reduction Act
there is a striking symmetry between the
inflation reduction Act and the European
green deal
both of them
are simultaneously a climate strategy
and a strategy for investment and growth
both of them include funding for just
transition
and both include regulatory standards
only on carbon pricing a very important
instrument the United States system is
still much more limited than ours
in other words
the two biggest and most advanced
economies in the world are now moving in
the same direction
and therefore I welcome the inflation
reduction act for its massive investment
in cleantech
but you might perhaps recall that we
discussed it already in November
some aspects of the inflation reduction
act were of concern to us and needed
Solutions
now I am happy to report that we have
found Solutions
on Friday President Biden and I
confirmed the understanding on electric
vehicles
that allows European car makers to get
access to the U.S market and thus to U.S
tax breaks
second we launched discussions on the
critical raw materials agreement
the aim is to ensure
that critical raw materials for electric
vehicle batteries
whether they are extracted or processed
in the European Union
are treated in the same way as if they
came from the United States and thus
this will secure strong Supply chains
for batteries in Europe
and ensure access to the U.S market
and my third point we started the
transparency Dialogue on incentives for
the clean tech industry
that's good news overall
but let me be clear negotiations can
only solve some of the most concerning
issues the big bulk of work
still lies with us in Europe
we Europeans need to get better at
nurturing our own clean tech industry
we need to speed up we need to simplify
procedures we need to Grant better
access to public and private finances
and if there's any doubt let me give you
three figures that underscore why this
is so important
the global investment
in the clean transition topped one
trillion dollars last year
and that's 30 percent more than the year
before
and if you look at the global market
for Net Zero Technologies
it is set to Triple by 2030.
so in other words the race is on the
race on who is going to be dominant in
this market in the future
and we must get our act together if we
want to stay Front Runners
we must nurture our own clean tech
Industrial base
both to create good jobs well-paying
jobs here in Europe
and of course to ensure access to the
clean Solutions we need so urgently
and that's what the European green deal
industrial plan is all about
the centerpiece of the green deal
industrial plan are two legal Acts
the one is the Net Zero industry Act
and the other one is the critical raw
materials Act
the commission is proposing those two
legal acts this week actually tomorrow
let me reflect on both
with the Net Zero industry act we are
setting the ambition
by 2030 we want to be able to produce at
least 40 percent of the clean tech that
we need here to fulfill our green
transition
and therefore the Net Zero industry Act
is all about speed speed and
facilitation
we're facilitating permitting we're
working with regulatory sandboxes we're
creating simpler state aid schemes
and we are following allowing for tax
breaks and the flexible use of EU funds
so in short The Net Zero industry act
provides speed
simplification and it provides funding
the second centerpiece is the critical
raw materials act which the college will
also adopt tomorrow
this is about securing the supply for
critical materials which are badly
needed for the digital and green
transition
these minerals as you know power phones
and electric vehicles the batteries the
chips the windmills the solar panels you
just name it
in other words we cannot function
without them the critical raw materials
and the demand for critical raw
materials will dramatically rise over
the next several years and decades but
and we've discussed that here in the
hemicycle before
as you all know
today the European Union depends heavily
on a few certain countries for these
strategic raw materials
just a few examples and you know plenty
of them
we get 98 of our Rare Earth Supply from
China
93 of our magnesium
from China
97 of our lithium from China and you can
continue this list over and over again
and honorable members we know that the
pandemic and the war have taught us a
bitter lesson about over dependencies
so if we want to be independent we
urgently need to strengthen our and
diversify
our supply chains with like is a
like-minded partner you can see
exemplary their European companies just
doing like just that
diversifying and strengthening our
supply chains
for instance sourcing low carbon nickel
to produce batteries here in the
European Union
and Canada
is not only a reliable partner
it also shares our values
it guarantees that raw materials are
mined with the highest standards for the
environment and for workers
so our critical raw materials act will
support these efforts by European
companies
we want to extract more Ores and
minerals here in the European Union
we want to boost our processing capacity
to at least 40 percent of annual
consumption
and of course we need to recycle more
again if I may jump back to Canada I
visited a company that is able
to recycle from old batteries
95 percent
of the lithium the Cobalt and the nickel
95 that's amazing to see that all
batteries so that's the future that's
what we have to have in the European
Union
so members of the European Parliament
this is our support for clean tech
companies
now when it comes to competitiveness the
issue is much broader it affects our
single market and we are having two
announcements to be published tomorrow
we all know that the single Market is
the foundation of our prosperity and our
competitiveness it's 30 years old this
year but the potential in this single
Market has not yet been fully exploited
if you look at various studies that look
at the single Market they show
that more than
700 billion euros could be released if
we used the full potential of the single
Market
and this starts with the capital markets
and with research and development
we know that we are strong because we
have good research and development and
then Market developments you know what
the
um
examples are the the MRNA vaccinations
were developed here in Europe This is
how we overcame the pandemic this is a
real good reason why this was developed
here and other
example is hydrogen research
there's no other place in the world
with between 2011 and 2020 more patents
for green hydrogen were registered than
here in Europe
these are just two examples and we
really need to focus on this area
Europeans have the goal by 2030
to have three percent of GDP on research
and development but we've had that goal
for a long time
we set that in 2002 first of all and if
we look at the speed
with which we are moving towards that
goal yes we are getting closer but very
slowly
and it's not enough
and others are much faster and they're
not sleeping
now as our expenditure is growing slowly
our proportion in the world
in r d expenditure have gone from 41
percent
but they've gone down to 31 percent
and therefore together with the Swedish
presidency and heads of state and
government I would like to propose that
this common European objective that we
increase research expenditure to look at
why investment in Innovation and
research and development
is so slow here and how we can improve
on this this is not only necessary for
researchers developers and companies but
it's also a very strong signal that we
are taking this very seriously we're
taking the issue of competitiveness in a
single Market very seriously
might
secondly
an issue that you hear time time again
bureaucracy
it's Europe's uh
companies and employees that make the
single Market one of the most attractive
markets in the world regardless of
whether we're talking about Industries
SM is family companies Market leaders
their success is Europe's success
and therefore we are doing our utmost to
facilitate their work
we know that the quality of public
management and the legal framework is
decisive for competitiveness
and therefore together we are paying
attention to this and we want to have
comprehensive impact assessments to
ensure that Europe's laws
do not burden Europe's companies but
that they support them instead often we
know
that it's not uh
just having to provide one certain
document that makes things difficult
it's the sum of all the documents that
needed to be provided therefore
we are going to go
do utmost to see what how we can improve
Europe's competitiveness and what we can
do without we will be presenting
specific proposals in Autumn to reduce
reporting obligations by 25 this is not
simple but we must try to do that
our political priorities are
the same because they are important that
is the European green deal
digitalization
and its geopolitical resilience
we set these goals three and a half
years ago they have been proven to be
good especially during these times of
crises we want to ensure that that
implementation is linked to less cost
for our smes in particular
now
we've shown this when extending
renewable energies how targeted
legislation can lead to a more flexible
approval procedures
this in future should be the rule it
should not be the exception
and just one final point
Europe's single Market is strong we can
be proud of this we need to do all we
can to keep it strong and to extend it
but in the future
that will be some key performance
indicators that will guide us in the
future
they can provide information about
whether Europe's economy is actually
becoming more competitive
and have discussions about this what
about the proportion of a private
investment what about the proportion of
companies with fast internet what about
participation in training all of this
data is available we don't need to
gather any more data but we can use this
data and using these kpis will allow us
to determine how we move forward
so it's not an assumption we have
concrete figures evidence-based figures
and there will be a report from the
commission one every year two Parliament
about how these kprs kpis are moving
with a worn out doorstep
with volatile Energy prices
at massive clean tech Investments
worldwide Europe has to up its game
I am looking forward to develop the
proposals we have put on the table today
this is our answer Long Live Europe
thank you very much the commission
president to now give the floor to the
representatives of the political group
starting by the president of the Epp
mounted Weber
president of the European Parliament
commission Council
their colleagues
good politics starts first of all with
the reality check
8 out of 10 Global Champions are from
the US
Apple's market value alone is bigger
than